oh yes all my underwear keeps falling
down Oh soon is like home two minute
warnings which okay oh my god they're
already using a blender there's so much
more activity over there sort of up here
we go
okay so right now we're headed to
Smorgasburg the tastiest trendiest
weekly food festival the LA has ever
known but first we got to make a stop in
Santa Monica
pick up chef Brittany Cassidy in the
2017 rav4 hello chef Brittany oh so nice
to finally meet you
nice to meet you how are you I'm doing
well are you excited I'm so excited this
is gonna be so much fun tell me a little
bit about Rustic Canyon we are a very
seasonal kitchen we change the menu
quite frequently almost nightly my mom's
side of the family we're Mexican and
American Indian my dad is French and
Italian I have like an overview of
cooking background okay girl let's get
real what are the contestants gonna be
cooking today it's gonna be a bit of a
challenge very delicious
some from the sea it's not gonna be
necessarily something that they're used
to doing I'm sure if I'm being honest
here I don't really eat anything from
the sea because my older sister scarred
me when I was a kid this is the perfect
opportunity for me to test the theory
that your taste buds change with age
absolutely
[Music]
hello Smorgasburg my name is Karl Monroe
and I am your humble host welcome to
tasty date night today we're here in
downtown Los Angeles to watch as two
couples put their relationship and
culinary skills to the ultimate test and
a cooking showdown whoever impresses our
judge the most can look forward to a
romantic date night at one of LA's
finest restaurants let's bring out our
first couple melody and Andy hi I'm Andy
from Santa Monica what hi I'm Andy and
I'm melody and we've been together about
five months she cooks and I stand there
and watch you make sure no fingers get
cut up right right quality well I think
melody will do fine
and if I managed not to trip over her or
knock anything over I think we should
have a pretty solid performance and
we're super competitive so he's like
playing it cool but we're gonna win what
she said help me welcome our second
couple Ari and Betsy hey I'm Betsy my
name is Ari and we've been together
while we've been married for ten years
we've been together for 17 so before we
had kids we used to cook together all
the time it was something we love to do
we cook surrounded by three chaotic boys
we're just happy to be here to get away
from them precisely we're tired and
insane I want to win this thing so we
could have an amazing dinner by
ourselves that is again the only way we
have a date is we have to win a game
show yeah this is real high stakes for
us yeah
Brittany what do we have in store for
our teams today I've decided to do
something that's very interactive for
couples so it's gonna be a crab tostada
oh let's see if that looks as good as it
sounds
so couples watch carefully because you
are going to have to make this oh hello
getting that crab
done first getting the crab cleaned that
would be the most important step
[Music]
all right we got a complicated recipe
this is going to be pretty challenging
so the last five minutes are going to
get away from you real quick I'll try to
do that first
all right without further ado let's put
30 minutes on the clock please
and let's get tasty I can't get my glove
on what are you working on oh boy I
think I've got this red cabbage to
finish our cassava kado cream
nonsense do I do both or do I just do go
on oh my god I was cut off in girl we
want to break those cuz those crab legs
are not going to fit in there crap I
don't know if I'm do it I think he
needed put the crab it on the newbie
side you've got a joint effort going
with the slaw and then on the other side
it looks like we have a delegation of
tasks you know we'll see what works
better I got a lot of aggression to work
out
I just cut this up I guess you're coming
fine yeah cilantro
she julienne the apples I did the red
cabbage she has more skills need to be
smaller ah mi slim I doing this right
I'm having trouble focusing how does
this work oh no I don't hear this one we
have them oh look at you okay we got
plenty of time oh crap bet you were hot
we overcooked the crab by about 2
minutes and 11 seconds look at you
Justin we are not comfortable unless
everything is past
Wow look at that take gear alright guys
we are under 10 minutes now it's quite
leg is empty what is happening I think
I'm using these things wrong whatever
found some amazing scissors that did
wonders in cutting the crab shell one
thing to always remember is if you put
liquid first in the blender and then all
the ingredients it sucks it down so you
get a really quick blend this is a nice
blender what the heck happens here got
to be boss stuff I feel like with crab
it's a lot of work for very little needs
oh my god there's like a handful of held
Pinot in here are we doing on time I
want girl I'm sure we're fine on time
yeah oh five minute warning
ah with that are you sure that's not
supposed to be cilantro in here no
cilantro Syme told me oh wait you're
right
see just put it back throw this away
yeah he's like think we have extra
cilantro I'm fairly sure they gave us
exactly at the Hana cilantro we're
supposed to use I think we still got
some left over look at re and Betsy
they're just like a little cartoon right
that's really spicy Joe how do you make
it less spicy put one tostada shell okay
take two
this is really nerve-racking my heart is
starting to beat a little faster here
for the design on the plate whatever you
want to do it's a bit of flair I don't
know the pic the video was like super
generous with the crabs crazy is it
crazy go what is bad that's a disaster
so here how does this whoops oh no oh do
you like the way that time wow it's too
late now audience can you guys help me
countdown five four three two one time
[Applause]
now turn to your partner and give them a
hug that was so intense so cute so come
on down REM Betty
all right the only thing I'm worried
about is our attention to detail oh
that's where you're worried about we
over get the crab we slice the cabbage
too thick and I added the lime to the
slaw without emulsifying it in the sauce
whatever emulsifying means look so I
like the cilantro garnish colorful very
colorful
let's eat again I want to dig in get in
here they've been there okay I eat with
my hands here we go this is our date
night we can get bread I'm eating crab
for you tasty eating hey oh my god huh
I like it all right you guys just make
some noise for RMSA how much fun it was
some what was amazing is about it was
delicious
we made the chef go like mmm so and then
also Carl who doesn't like crab was like
into it we've learned that your
perfectionism is important thank you
how are you ego I think I contained the
missteps on my part Prarie fairly well
so I'm pretty confident you're not
giving yourself enough credit he cooked
the crab which was a big component you
pulled your weight I'm gonna break all
right break it for me girl the knife
cuts on the Apple are really nice you
don't want anything too big so I'm gonna
go straight halfsies okay let's just get
into it
that's good not very delicious good
Julian the dice on it is really nice so
you can actually get a little bit more
in each writer adds a nice freshness
mm-hmm let's make some noise
good about it we thought both dishes
look really pretty
did some nice words she didn't choke or
anything so she complimented the
Giuliani multiple times each time
referencing the Apple I wouldn't have it
so no obviously two very different
approaches to this dish
you kind of taste almost the
personalities in the dishes yeah the
first one had a lot more seasoning I
liked the amount of crab it's a crab
tostada knife cuts on their slaw was a
little difficult to eat go with melody
and Andy they were a lot calmer and that
translated in their flavors not as much
salt and lime but yet they had a lot of
precision in their cup but the portion
was really much less than Betsy and Ari
you can tell that both couples had a
really good time which really is the
whole point of this I have a definitive
winner in my book
welcome back come on I hear you guys the
winner of tasty date night LA is Betsy
Inari
[Applause]
so happy I cannot tell you how
meaningful that was to me
I was nervous though because that both
dishes looked exactly identical to me
but I forgot about taste that's a big
thing oh yeah that turns out to me so
excited to go to a restaurant with
awesome food without children in it yeah
so we'll see you at tasty all-stars yes
yeah we're pretty devastated you'd like
to win but then again it's really about
the process and having fun we had fun
yeah it was really fun to cook together
and we didn't learn another recipe and
definitely can try to get it no thank
you to Smorgasburg for hosting us thank
you to my amazing audience this has been
tasty date night brought to you by
Toyota
[Applause]